the Fox News had a thing about Maxwell
and they used a picture of Epstein and
Melania and Dwayne but then they propped
out Trump and they're apologizing on
accident cuz you know Fox News in
chopper very they're pretty cool they're
usually pro-trump yeah so this is the
actual yeah I would say that all three
of those things are there are three
different purposely popping off but this
is the actual thing I mean both sides do
it CNN does their share of Photoshop
[ __ ] all right why didn't you lane
Maxwell or whatever her name is go to
France where they don't have where she
would have been kind of safe with her
billions I thought she was out the per
second he came back I don't know well
the question is maybe she knows
something that we don't know maybe she's
got an ace in the hole maybe she already
worked out a deal yeah we'll see right
yeah cuz she's too smart she knows they
were gonna track her down here in the
state yeah she bought a house like
driving distance from the DA yeah so
they had to literally come and pick her
up to the cars so it's like she I think
she worked out a deal I think that names
are going to be named oh yeah and it's
interesting I want to see what happens
because but the question is over the
she's got Kovac dude and she's 60
something oh so now she'll be in the
hospital at the end of the day if she
was working and Epstein were working for
a foreign intelligence agency let's say
like the Israelis the Israelis can do
what the [ __ ] that the Mossad can get to
you I would imagine yeah so I'm not a
big conspiracy guy I don't know if
Jeffrey Epstein hung himself I don't
know I'm not gonna get into it I don't
know the details of his shot I mean uh
Rogan was like look into it Brian you
know and rogas not even a conspiracy he
actually thinks it Jeff Preston didn't
kill himself
so what the [ __ ] do I know but I will
say this is if it just Jo Lane it just
Lane Maxwell makes it through this
or she mysteriously dies of coma yeah
please do I don't know what name she has
what's that I said hopefully she makes
it through it I want to know what
[ __ ] information she has yeah that's
the big question
no you're talking about [ __ ] big
names oh man you're talking about like
and if you're talking about underage
girls you're talking about like I don't
I didn't read a lot about where they're
like 14 year olds 15 year olds yeah well
there's probably video I don't know
that's that yeah that's conspiracy that
they had video running to make sure
maybe one of the efficacy of two bunch
of gals were like him a twenty-something
but it's different yeah you know there's
gotta be very powerful men [ __ ] in
their pastor Bill Clinton and then also
because he's already got a litany of
this behavior history I'm tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]